si el presidente de baile terminó hace
unos minutos ese discurso desde acá
desde la casa blanca sale para delaware
pero antes dijo que al pueblo americano
entiende entiende que la cultura del
estadounidense es del porte de armas
pero le pidió hacer conciencia para que
haya una prohibición en el porte y la
compra de armas de asalto enfatizó en
este compra y venta de armas de asalto
porque son precisamente estas armas las
que se han usado en los recientes
tiroteos en tulsa en búfalo y en balde
además del más sangriento de todos en la
historia reciente de eeuu que fue
también en los ángeles el presidente joe
biden dio unas cifras bastante
alarmantes dijo por ejemplo que desde el
tiroteo no balde se han reportado 20
tiroteos más en eeuu lo que pasa es que
no llegan a los medios de comunicación
dijo por ejemplo que más niños mueren
que policías al año en eeuu pero por
causa de tiroteos y que precisamente la
causa número uno
muertes en los niños son los tiroteos
que tiene que parar esta tendencia esta
realidad en eeuu le robó el presidente
yo bailé al senado específicamente que
por favor haga algo cualquier cosa pero
que haga algo porque cada vez que él va
y visita un lugar donde un tiroteo eso
es lo que le piden los ciudadanos por
favor haga algo para detener esta
situación
cristóbal ese es el pedido de los
ciudadanos y esto es un debate que haya
tenido lugar en el senado en eeuu pero
cuál es la propuesta entonces qué hacen
los demócratas desde el congreso
muchos demócratas están pidiendo que se
vuelva a activar esta prohibición de
venta de armas de asalto que ya estuvo
ya tuvo lugar en eeuu en el 94 los
demócratas lograron esta prohibición en
el porte y la compra de armas de asalto
esta prohibición de los 10 años se
terminó en el 2004 desde entonces los
republicanos han frenado nueva
legislación para prohibir la compra de
armas al día salto pero concretamente
piden que si esto no se puede entonces
que se suba la edad de 18 o 21 años para
poder adquirir un rifle de asalto
también piden expandir la red y expandir
la revisión de antecedentes para las
personas que quieren comprar estas armas
en línea y también en los shows de armas
en estos eventos grandes que se hacen de
armas alrededor de eeuu y por último
también piden pues prohibir
se ve que se venda estas municiones esta
munición de largo alcance que es
precisamente la que permite que estas
personas puedan disparar esta cantidad
de balas